j'ai toujours vécu pour les 400 mètres
d'une course de savoir pourquoi tu te
marché faillite
voilà tu es là
d'ailleurs pendant ces 10 secondes heure
de paris
courir ou mourir tu te rappelles
j'étais libre
aujourd'hui regarde moi aussi je
m'attache à l'essentiel [ __ ] les
femmes il ya
mon équipe on est au delà de la folie là
c'est carrément scindé
sa famille ses textes suivra jusqu'à la
mort
quel on a beau rouler aussi vite qu'on
peut
les chats pas à son passé
et le mieux ça faisait un bail tu as tes
frères
viens de me rattraper je vais détruire
tout ce que tu as d'hommes
non mais
je voyais à rien de plus puissant que
l'amour de la famille mais quand ça
tourne la haine et à la rocker
illyriennes plus dangereux luz tu dois
tuer sa famille
je suis prête si tu lui aussi
tu es mon frère
être à jamais
de ma famille
[Musique]